ou je parle des mecs et des meufs là des
meufs elle partait le matin frère la
meuf tu savais pas où elle était frère
va la chercherou elle va la chercher va
la chercher mon frère tu daron ma
grand-mère tu crois ma grand-mère tu
crois elle partait mon frère alors elle
était sérieuse
hein pas la famille pas la famille
croisoi tu crois quoi tu crois mon
grand-père tu crois que tu vas appeler
ma grand-mère frère elle partait le
matin quoi elle revenait avec deux
aubergines est parti toute la journée tu
crois qu' va vous êtes des ouf une
courgette et de aubergine une courgette
c'est ma grand-mère
[Applaudissements]
dit pardon mamie pardon mamie
merci dans la lune pour allez Andrea qui
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rejoint mer spéci anné 90 spécial années
90 alors ce soir juste après l'émission
bah on va retourner dans les années 90
avec un très joli prime et ben pour la
dernière dépêche de 2023 je me suis dit
que ça pourrait être cool aussi de
partir un petit peu voir ce qui s'est
passé dans la politique et l'actualité
des années 90 et forcément qui dit
politique en 90 dit présidentielle de
1995 où il s'est passé pas mal de
choses et ouais il y avait détenu de
malad dans les meetings wou joli ton
petit bateau et harl Laguiller la
candidate de lut ouvrière était pas
encore hyper au point avec les duplexes
madame lag vous êtes sur fr on vous
écoute oui allez-y madame lauiller
madame laaguiller on vous écoute on vous
écoute allez-y bien c'est à vous madame
laaguiller-ce que je devant vous devant
vous allez-y madame allez-y je peux y
aller oui vous pouvez y
aller les Français se rend au pour le
premier tour et apparemment oui oui
avait aussi le droit de vote en
95 bonjour monsieur vous allez voter oui
vous rendez au Breau de vote là oui oui
oui c'est important pour vous de voter
oui oui
oui et une fois dans les bureaux de vote
l'ambiance entre les journalistes était
pas fouichon non
plus Figur parmi les candidats il avait
déjà un pied à l'isé celui-ci est-ce que
là vous êtes en mesure de faire déjà un
pronostic
oui oui le deuxè tour
éliminé tout comme Édouard Baladur
éliminé au premier tour mais qui nous
lesgar cette phrase mythique c'est
Monsieur Jospin et Monsieur Chirac qui
seront
présents je vous demande de vous
arrêter je vous demande de vous arrêter
magique alors le second tour
confronéirac et Jospin et apparemment le
débat avait conquis les Français F ils
sont aussi nul l'un que l'autre ça m'a
profondément
ennuyé préè plus marrant oui le résultat
de cette élection on le connaitt tous
évidemment Jacques Chirac élu président
de la République française et ouais mais
ce qu'on connait moins c'est ce gros
scouple lché quelques minutes seulement
après le
résultat j'ai oublié une toute petite
chose tout à l'heure il paraît qu'un
jour il paraît qu'un jour Monsieur
Chirac monsieur Chirac a fait quoi il a
détourné des fonds non pire truer les
élections Jacques Chirac le président de
la républ a volé des fromages ah c'est
Texas oui une voisine c'est
allez actu à l'époque tourne à fond
làdessus
alors tout au long des années 90 bah
c'était un peu le Parti socialiste qui
était au pouvoir en soit entre la
présidence de François mitteran puis la
cohabitation Chirac Jospin bref tout se
passe plutôt bien au PS youi ce soir les
socialistes vont faire la fête dîner
flonfon il y aura même paraî-il un feu
d'artifice sur le lac de B c'était la
grande époque du PS que du beau monde
Jospin Fabius alors pour rappel RAR
c'est celui qui applaudissait comme
quand tu fais des petites proutes avec
tes
[Musique]
mains la gauche des années 90 et surtout
de nombreuses revendications sociales
avec des manifestants au tenu hyper
crédibles à la gare Monparnasse les
premiers envahisseurs arrivent du
Sud-Ouest c'est jour de fête ou jour de
colère de
colère ça l'air en tout cas à l'époque
de nombreux jeunes se lancent en
politique comme ce petit gars qui
faisait ses premiers pas au PS et moi je
je serais très dur à l'égard de ceux qui
onont cassé cette organisation ah pardon
François et même si de nos jours ils ont
l'air plutôt sympa les
[Musique]
politiques et ben en 94 Ops ils avaient
Henri Emmanuelli et c'était pas aussi
cool ouais aisou Henry Emmanuelli n'est
pas chasseur mais quand il dégane c'est
pour faire mouche d'accord mais comparé
à aujourd'hui la politique c'est un peu
devenu Planète Rap on va pas se mentir
ta gueule trou
trsieur et ben l'époque la bouc une
phrase cétait efficace Tacon dit déjà la
parole est d'argent et le silence est
d'or ça faire dans
l'efficacité chaque semaine dans la
Dépêche d' d'habitude on finit avec la
météo des réseaux problème 90 ah ouais
alors je propose de finir sur un petit
top 5 des meilleures images des années
90 allez vas-y c'est fait vasy c'est
faitendu vasy c'est fait c'est numéro 5
en pleine campagne pour 95 je crois que
jacté légèrement à
l'époque mais
c'est
c'est numéro 4 lors de la soirée
électorale de 95 on avait pas tous la
même définition d'une ambiance bon
enfant pour définir l'ambiance comme une
ambiance bon enfant il y en a même qui
numéro 3 c'est France 2 qui est tombé
sur Fran madiu en 94 un supporter du
Tour de France un peu trop à
[Applaudissements]
fond vous allez depuis ce matin vous
criez comme ça ah ouais je louper deux
ou TR parce que à midi j'étaé mangé bah
ouais numéro 2 si on avait le si on sa
que la politique est un chemin seé d'
bûche le Nort dû faire un peu plus gaffe
en 92 cette fois c'est officiel les
socialistes contre-attaquent monsie j
s'il vous
plaît et enfin enfin numéro 1 ma prve
des prêves celle qui définit le mieux la
France à mon avis en 98 des passagers un
peu mécontents de la CNCF l'ont bien
fait savoir son gé pour changer c'est
toujours pareil ça fait 24 ans que je
les supporte j'en ai r la casquette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
raent qui fallait pas louper jeis vous
parler d'un mec de 23 ans qui a juste
voulu acheter un disque dur neuf et qui
s'est retrouvé face à des photos d'un
homme de 80 80 piges à poil pas
Gille le rêve c'est le disque du G si tu
foutis sur ce disque dur bordel regardez
ce
bail il y a quelques jours un
informaticien de 23 ans décide de
s'acheter un disque dur externe mais en
le connectant à son ordinateur le jeune
homme constate que sont déjà enregistré
sur l'appareil des lettres des pièces
d'identité et de nombreux documents
personnels appartenant à un octogénère
j'ai vu les dossiers et je me suis dit
eh qu'est-ce que c'est et parmi ces
différents fichiers l'homme de 23 ans
découvre des photos et des vidéos
intimes de l'homme de 80 ans qui
apparaît tout nu quand j'ai regardé les
image j'ai été choqué et si un enfant
avait acheté ce disque dur le jeunehomme
qui s'est dit scandalisé dénonce un
manque de protection de la part de
l'enseigne qui c'est de son côté excusé
auprès de
l'octogénère ah
ouais ils ont mis longtemps à savoir ce
qui s'était passé et en fait
l'octogéèire a voulu faire réparer son
ordinateur et la firme lui dit c'est
impossible donc il dit bah j'en rachète
un œuf mais éliminer ce qu'il y avait
sur l'ancien ordinateur et un gars de la
société de vente a pris le disque dur
externe pour purger l'ordinateur mais
après il l'a remis en vente et c'est
pour ça que le jeune l'a acheté il a oué
surtout qu'il y a 80 ans met des newes
sur un disque dur la vraie question